[Music]
sebastian stan looks completely
unrecognizable but no need to worry
because the actor's filming his new
thriller a different man in nyc
it's really wild here's a first look at
sebastian in character as edward a man
who undergoes facial reconstructive
surgery and searches for a fresh start
the 39 year old actor totally transforms
for the role wearing full face
prosthetics plus a green bomber jacket
and khaki pants and i was like who are
you
it's unclear what scene sebastian was
working on but one theory that's him as
edward before surgery also in the film
adam pearson who actually has
neurofibromatosis type 1 which causes
non-cancerous tumors to grow on nerve
tissue
little is known about the plot but some
fans think adam plays an actor in a
stage production who portrays
sebastian's character in his former life
but of course sebastian is no stranger
to on-screen transformations
what the hell is this the actor recently
scored a prime time emmy nom for his
portrayal of motley crue drummer tommy
lee in the drama series pam and tommy
every second it passes this tape could
be spreading baby we will get it back
back in january sebastian told et about
working with lily james who also totally
transformed to play pamela anderson we
had the the very best hair and makeup
team
uh we could have asked for and it was a
pretty crazy process because i think it
took
uh two hours for myself and then three
hours for lilly almost every morning and
then you pile that on to a 12-hour day
and it definitely gets interesting by
the end even wilder sebastian and
lilly's first meeting yeah it was when
they were both in costume the first time
i saw her physically was actually
as pam and then transformed and i didn't
really see her outside of the wig and
everything's till the end of the them
you know and also i'd forgotten that she
had an accent she's from england i was
like don't you have an accent but um but
she was very transformed and it was
pretty impressive
it'll be interesting to hear how people
on the different man set reacted to
sebastian in character all i know is
this guy sure knows how to commit for a
role
[Music]